so i'm an american i grew up in oregon
which is awesome and i went to school in
canada also awesome montreal great city
i was always surprised though because
canadians think that american beer sucks
and then americans don't even think
about canadian beer because really
canada
so
i actually wanted to find out which one
is actually better
what i found out when i looked into it
was that because of import and export
laws a lot of canadians just never get a
chance to taste any kind of american
beers and by the same token there's all
these new craft breweries in canada that
americans aren't tasting at all
i went over to angel city brewery in
downtown los angeles and i talked to
this guy dieter who's their master
brewer and i wanted to know what he
thought about canadian beer versus
american beer and whether there's
actually a difference have you had much
canadian beer
i have not had much canadian beer um
you know i had lebat
so if you're just like having some beers
and someone says to you
american craft brewers are not nearly as
good as canadian craft burrowers what
would you say
don't uh count out the americans
and i would encourage them to try our
beers so as a beer drinker if i'm having
two ipas
how do i decide which ipa is better
actually whichever one you like the best
is really the better one so after having
a couple beers with theater we went down
to san diego to meet up with this guy
scott who imports canadian beers into
the states
we want to ask scott what's going on
canada why do canadians think that
american beer is not as good as canadian
beer and is it true what do you want
americans to know about canadian beer
that there's much more to it than just
one
pigeonholed type of beer it's not just
it's not just molson why do canadians
think that america doesn't have good
compared i think that canadians think
that
these guys are a little bit far behind
because you know a majority of their
beer is sort of like water yeah living
on the border especially up like in
michigan detroit and that kind of stuff
you would hear all the stories about how
people would just cross the border to
get canadian beer so if someone put a
gun to your head and said what country
makes better beer you're american you
import canadian beers what would you say
oh it's so tough i live in san diego
we're filming this in san diego and this
is sort of the epicenter for craft beer
in the u.s
and there's amazing beers here but i do
feel like there are canadian craft beers
i know i'll dodge it i'll die
i'll dodge it
there are some beers that are just
kicking in canada and that i that i
would prefer to drink absolutely over
u.s craft beer so scott gave us a bunch
of canadian beers we're taking them back
to the la office and we're gonna have a
blind taste test with americans and
canadians and we're gonna find out once
and for all who has the better beer
there's some strong canadian like
underdog wolverine style beers out there
i've had molson that's that's a canadian
beer right i think canada has way better
beer canadians make beer i don't love
beer to be honest usa i think america's
gonna take it home i think canadian beer
is better than american beer america has
a great beer industry
let's see if canadians can top it
citrusy piney feel this one tastes like
a strip mall sports bar this one is
refined the first one was like gross is
the best way to describe it i feel like
i'm having a good dinner a good meal
with this one this is the one i picked
right here
yeah
obviously
american it's american this is canadian
oh yeah raincoast yeah yeah
almost no aroma
ah
yeasty
like talking with my grandma
off
what do we got kanye we're going back
four more
gosh darn it
this is like a beachy beer this is not
an ipa this one tastes literally like
nothing this is an ipa
oh man kanye
you did it i did it yes
god
tastes like i've been on the street for
a little while it's a
mustache that can talk kind of man's
beer this is a michigan beer
i mean michigan is almost canada america
no
what
oh god
yeah i could have a boot of that this is
like the way harder beer oh
it's like if you need a beer to have
your back
by like throwing bottles 20 feet away
from the conflict in a club you're gonna
go with this beer i am just like had
enough beers and i'm like yeah
all tastes good now but if you're like
on the street and a guy has a knife
and you're like which one of these beers
is willing to get stabbed once or twice
to do more damage to the other guy i'm
gonna go with this beer
whoa
no no no here we go to be honest i do
think ryan gosling would be better in a
fight than kanye
this is the beer that you drink after
the better beer is all run out reminds
me of my grandpa
they both smell like cheap college beers
because there's just nothing to these
this one is more bubbles though i'm
gonna go
yes
so let's see how i did
all right kanye
there's a lot of work to test out a
question i've had since college but what
we did learn is that both countries have
great beers you should try beers from
other countries even though america won
by like a hair the thing to do is not
talk about other countries beer and
remember that if a country makes a lot
of beer it's probably a pretty cool
country so you should hang out with
people from that country america and
canada we're coming together we're
getting drunk